we started shooting that film with I
believe about 21 pages that we had
agreed on so after 10 days we had
nothing left to shoot and I would never
ever recommend that you make a movie
that way it's just the way Ridley likes
to make a movie you know Ridley likes to
sort of like feel it as he as he's doing
it and and he'll get to a point where
the character I need a moment for this
character that gives me that you know so
then he'll go and hunt down what that's
going to be so I said to Ridley I want
the character to say something like that
you know when he greets soldiers from
his uh regiment and stuff you know he
should say that when he's leaving them
you know that's his his sort of uh thing
you know so uh and I said I want him to
say for a anorm and really
[Laughter]
goes what does that
mean I said it means strength and all he
go say
that